so what's an atom and I am is
something that builds up everything so
oh that went on the small particle isn't
it yeah that's a very small particle you
know it was a small individual part of
an element in further divided atom into
protons and neutrons protons and
neutrons is that it it's just a small
little thing that's made up of protons
electrons and a neutron all of the
materials and get them things are made
up of of atoms and then you've got the
the nucleus and the electrons that go
around the outside that will be an atom
which is made up of the nucleus and
electrons that can be done to these
electrons was in around in different
scale different orbits and it's mainly
mainly nothing
this is how it's represented yep is the
proton and that's the electron and then
you have a neutron in there as well and
this thing spins around but so it seems
most people are comfortable with the
idea that all matter is made up of atoms
that an atom is the fundamental building
block of matter and that these atoms are
made up of smaller particles called
protons electrons and neutrons but after
that the details get a little bit hazy
it looks a bit like Saturn so what I'd
like to do is actually build an atom or
at least a model of an atom so I've got
here a proton Neutron and electron the
simplest atom that I can make is
hydrogen because hydrogen consists of
only two particles a little positive
proton and a tiny little negative
electron they're attracted to each other
because of their opposite charge and so
many people think of the electron as
orbiting about the proton that's not
strictly true I mean it's not like a
planet going around the Sun but because
the proton is positively charged and the
electron is negatively charged
they're both attracted towards each
other now what would happen if we took
our hydrogen atom which consists just of
a proton and an electron and we added a
neutron into the nucleus
this hasn't really changed anything
electrically because the proton and the
electron are still opposite charges and
attracting each other and the neutron is
neutral so it doesn't really affect this
interaction so the atom that we have
here is still hydrogen except it's just
a little bit more massive you could say
it's heavier because the neutron is
there but I'm how does that really
affect the behavior of this atom well
the truth is it's not that different to
regular hydrogen and this is what we
call an isotope an isotope is a
different version of the same element so
it has the same number of protons in the
nucleus by just a different number of
neutrons